government is this great moral Alchemist
or moral launderer things that you would
never think to do in your own life that
you know would be wrong in your own life
suddenly become not only acceptable but
even a positive good if it's done
through the political system Sheldon
Richman I'm editor of the Freeman and
have been for about 14 years and most
people grow up with the libertarian idea
that they shouldn't hit other kids
shouldn't take their stuff without
permission and should keep their
promises or they you know don't lie and
that easily can be translated into
respect life property and keep your
contract so most children do grow up
with that and in their personal eyes
once they're adults they pretty much
abide by that very few people would you
know go next door to their neighbor and
say you know with a gun or with a subtle
threat of force saying give me your
money because I want to do something
good with it or you know commit some
other sort of crime most the most people
that would be unthinkable I don't think
it's only because they're afraid of the
police coming I think they also feel
that's inconsistent with the way they
want to live in a civilized society so
at that level they're kind of
libertarians but at the other level once
they trance once they're thinking in a
political context the rules all seem to
change is if government is this great
moral alchemist or moral launderer
things that you would never think to do
in your own life that you know would be
wrong in your own life suddenly become
not only acceptable but even a positive
good if it's done through the political
system how the concept of the individual
has changed over the years is that's a
that's a difficult question I'm sure I
couldn't give a full answer to that even
with a lot of time I think you could
make a case in many ways it's better we
have I think we have a fuller deeper
appreciation of self-realization you
know all the stuff that's going on all
these fat and fad movements that have
gone on over the years have all left
probably some good good even if in a lot
of ways that maybe they weren't good in
some ways but I think we have a sense
that yes you have a right to make the
most of your life and there was probably
less of that and more or maybe
communitarianism
in the in the in older days so I'm not
one as people who take the position that
we
we've never never been less free I think
that's been criticized by David Bo's and
other people and I think that's true I
mean you can go back to times where
we're certainly some of our ancestors
depending on exactly who you are
particularly if you're a black person or
a woman
your ancestors exactly where had it much
worse than you have it today we had
chattel slavery and you had legal
disabilities for women so that's that
has all been improved and the and we
should never want to shy away from that
it's just ridiculous if it won't sell to
the average person to say we've never
been less free that's just wrong but you
can point out ways you can break it down
you have to disaggregate it and there
are ways in which were less free there
other ways were more free well we're
less free in related to search and
seizure and surveillance I mean a lot of
this has accelerated since 9/11 but I
think you can find the beginnings of
this earlier than that where there's I
think there's more surveillance
warrantless wiretapping the Obama
administration wants to broaden those
laws so that they can get into Internet
information including browser history
that the moment they're not able to get
we have a thing called National Security
Letters where the FBI basically can
write its own warrants and then go go to
a bank or something to demand records
and then the the bank of someone else's
records and then the bank can't even
tell the person the target that the FBI
has come to us and asked for information
on you so you you as the target can't go
to court and challenge it the way a
traditional warrant could be a challenge
so I think that's that's definitely a
way the most of the ways probably are
related to national security and of
course that's always been the state's
way of justifying greater powers but you
see it in the eminent domain area right
there's much more eminent domain where
it's not for a road not that I'm
approving of that but at least it was
they were for more narrow reasons right
so-called public purposes public purpose
that the term of which you know is in
the Constitution was interpreted in a
much more an hour away it had to be a
bridge or Road you know a post office
now of course they can take it for a
fancy mall or something along those
lines so we're less free that the
property owners are less free that way
we're seeing encroachments on our
freedom in health
waise smoking bans and you can't have
the trans fats or you have to put the
calorie counts on menus and then of
course we haven't talked about Obamacare
that hasn't fully kicked in inevitably
we're gonna have to see more controls
there because they're trying to do
something that's impossible which is
been the cost curve downward while
expanding demand and and and they say
not intruding on our choices where you
can't do all three things so something's
got to give and I have a feeling they're
not going to move in a libertarian
direction when they realize their
problems I think they're going to move
to more controls more overt rationing so
I think there is less freedom in our
future unless we can make some change
there technology is a very important
element I think in a libertarian
direction on net now the state obviously
can use technology I already mentioned
what Obama wants to do with surveilling
the internet so there are dangers there
but I think one of the things that maybe
no libertarian for the most part even
anticipated was how much we can use
technology number one to watch the state
and number two I mean people are using
their cell phones to to catch cops right
doing bad things and they don't like
that they're striking back they're
making that a crime apparently but there
are other ways that we can use
technology to get around the state first
of all let's lower the cost of things
like publishing and and music
reproduction it's calling into question
the intellectual property law which I
believe is an infringement of individual
liberty it's it's making that almost
unenforceable and I think eventually it
will become unenforceable industries and
and kind of lines of work which would
have been out of the question a few
years ago because the upfront capital
cost was so high is nail within your
reach you can do things at home right
film editing and film and music
production and publishing of course the
whole internet blogging has made it easy
to spread the word spread the
libertarian word I think libertarians
have exploited that very nicely and
hopefully we'll be finding even better
ways to get to undermine the state
illegitimate the state technology I
think is one of the great bright spots
as far as the future liberty code
you